a special advisor to the Philadelphia
76ers and the dad of the general manager
of the team Jerry Colangelo Basketball
Hall of Famer kind enough to call back
into the show
here he is Jerry how are you doing today
I'm fine it's nice to be with you all
right let's start with the the trade in
principle there's a conversation and
lots of reports as to what the Sixers
are sending to the the Celtics and that
it could not just be the draft choice
that's in question here this year or
next but another one how many draft
choices are involved in this trade Jerry
well rich the details are being worked
out as we as we speak and you know
nothing can be announced until the night
of the draft anyway so between now and
then there's going to be a lot of
speculation and you know all of the
details will come out soon the way I
would describe it for sure is I think
it's a win win for for two teams in that
Philly assuming this goes through has
the opportunity to select a guy that has
a personal potential would be a real
star because of skill length size
everything going for him he has the he
looks like the whole package and we're
referring to folks if that's the player
selected Boston on the other hand has
other assets they may be packaging there
may be free agents involved it's hard to
say you know I have a lot of respect for
Danny Ainge he knows what he's doing and
so this is one of those deals that could
end up being a plus plus for both so in
terms of what you just said Jerry um you
know T's when they're crossed and I's
when they're dotted in conversations
when they're fluid sometimes don't
result in an actual trade being
consummated are you saying as we're
currently speaking that there's a
possibility that this does not go down
in this traffic no I I didn't say that I
just said there's a there's a process
that takes place and ultimately no deal
could be announced until the
the draft night anyway and so sometime
between now and then I think all of this
will be worked out so in terms of drafts
as I know certainly first hand in the
NFL having covered 15 of those yeah
there's always tons of parsing you can
you can pick apart anything and with
faults there's free-throw shooting and
then there's also the fact that like Ben
Simmons he did not lead his team to an
NCAA Tournament berth what what are the
concerns on those fronts for the Sixers
organization best you can hear yeah I
would raise a good point and that is we
could take any player at the top of the
draft and as we you know really dissect
the player his pluses minuses upside
what's the downside there's no perfect
there's no perfect pick so so much of it
pertains to a team's personal opinion on
a player and needs that a team may have
and so you know the one thing I'm very
certain of is that in the last year much
has come together for Philadelphia after
some really painful years of losing big
time and so you know I think we're on
the on the verge of really turning the
franchise around last year was a step
and indeed showed that he could be a
very very special player if he stays
healthy and you know we're assuming
Simmons is going to be good Simmons we
expect and you know I like the pieces
and I think there's a very bright future
for the 76ers Jerry Colangelo special
advisor to the Sixers as also the
managing director of USA Basketball
joining me here on the Rich Eisen show
when know when when do you think the
Sixers can actually put all these young
pieces together and start winning
basketball games and challenging teams
like the Celtics LeBron's Cavs for as
long as they're constituted that way
Jerry well you know you
mentioned earlier you know Paul George
and you know the free agent market and
how things are are changing this is a
different kind of a league at how its
operated in movement player movement etc
than it was ten years ago that's for
certainly um I think what you hope to do
is put pieces together and give those
give that collective group an
opportunity to develop together and as
you look at the core of what
Philadelphia is putting together there's
a core that if they stay healthy it live
up the expectations will be one of those
teams that can challenge anyone so let's
see how it all plays out over the next
couple of years this is not a flip the
switch you know all of a sudden you're a
contender kind of a situation but boy
it's all moving in the right direction
how much is the fact that the Warriors
are a super team and the Cavs appear to
be one and certainly if they can add
George or whomever that it pays to just
build for the long haul and wait LeBron
if not the Warriors out Jerry well I
think you raised another good point and
that is it is what it is in the NBA and
there are super a couple of teams that
have separated themselves from the pack
everyone else is doing their job trying
to build trying to grow trying to
compete and you know all things come to
an end as you well know you know teams
don't win forever players you know get
hurt players get old players move on and
free agency and so it's a it's a moving
target stay on course stick to your guns
develop your own players and I think
that's a key to this and then you may be
adding a free agent here or there and
then you're ready to truly compete is
this a good thing for the NBA
super team's journey I you know I think
there's pluses and minuses I don't have
a problem with it
first of all I like to give credit to
those who have become that kind of a
product
uh give them credit for doing that and
there's something to be said for the
great rivalries between great teams and
you know everyone else would like to be
one of them so when uh what do you think
if you wouldn't mind putting on your
decades of experience on this front
Jerry what do you think the Pacers
options are right now now that it got
out there that Paul George wants out and
even mentioned the Lakers is a specific
team what what what options you think
are available to the Pacers right now
well not a lot you know it's it's kind
of a bad situation to have your player
you know publicly state that you know
he's going to be gone and so you know
just it's it's a it's a difficult
dilemma for for the Pacers and it'll be
interesting to see how it does play out
well I mean if the do you think they
could pry loose say the Lakers second
overall pick for something like this
it's certainly if the Cavs are in the
mix or or the Celtics are in the mix
Gerry well free agency you know is if
you if you're willing to wait for free
agent and his timing you don't have to
worry about compensation you don't have
to worry about anything like that
conversely you know our team's going to
be interested in the player any player
who has indicated I'm only going to be
there for a cup of coffee because I want
to be somewhere else you know a year
from now that that is not an easy you
know there's no real easy answer here is
the point rich and know there's a report
on the worldwide leader in sports ESPN
that the Sixers turned down an offer
from the Bulls for the third overall
selection in the form of Jimmy Butler is
there any truth to that Gerry I have no
idea and the reason I say that rich is
that I am now in transit to Philadelphia
for the week okay for the draft and I'm
going to get caught up at all these
rumors a night when I get there
so I'm just trying to figure out what
you know because I
certainly know that Butler is extremely
talented and I'm just now going to go
hypothetical with you here what is more
valuable a bona fide all-star in a prime
of his career or a draft choice for
somebody who's 18 19 20 years old what
how is that viewed within the Ndege
community
well again you can't just isolate it it
depends on what else you have on your
roster and where your team developed in
is so it could fit very well for one
team and not necessarily for another and
then also the ages the ages of your core
players you know that I think timing is
everything when you add a great player a
free agent player to your core players
so each team has to make that kind of a
determination as to where they are and
what fits best for them and now what's
the report on Lonzo ball the
conversation involved him and relation
to his dad and drafting him in the NBA
Jerry I think teams are going to draft
according to what they see in the way of
talent and someone's potential and ball
has great potential he is who he is with
his strengths and weaknesses but I think
everyone expects him they have an
outstanding NBA career and and let it go
at that
and no issues with the dad nobody's
discussing that right now well I I'm not
privy to what other people are
discussing okay and that's one thing
that we in Philadelphia will not have to
be concerned with okay any truth to the
rumor that you're considering Lavar ball
for the three-on-three Olympic team
sorry
I mean 2.2 points a game come on now
right you know I gave I gave up a lot of
responsibilities in with USA basketball
other than the senior men's team and and
that's because Popovich put the put it
on me when when I asked him to be the
next
going to replace Coach K he said I'll do
it but I have one condition that you
stay and you don't retire and that I
don't know I won't say force me but it
been my decision for me to stick with it
and that's the reason I'm continuing
okay so if I had less journalistic
scruples I could say the headline is
Jerry Colangelo says Greg Popovich wants
levar ball on the USA Olympic team that
basically was that that was the answer I
just got I said that's not the headline
I don't think so it's okay I need to
workshop that one so that sounds like
fake news Jerry thanks for the call
appreciate it thank you rich they've got
her that's Jerry Colangelo special
advisor to the 76ers the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country
and audience isn't it amazing you can
download an app with your thumbprint you
should download our app with your
thumbprint